Let's talk about those tens of millions of
dollars that Donald Trump raised after the
election and before January 6th meant to fight
voter fraud in the courts and met to support
the Republican incumbent senators in Georgia,
both of whom lost.
Donald Trump spent none of that money on the
things he claimed he was raising the money
for.
And of course, anybody who looked at the fine
print as we did would have predicted exactly
this 76 million dollars Donald Trump raised
for what ultimately was a slush fund, claiming
I need the money to challenge the results
of the election.
I need the money to make court filings.
I need the money to help Republicans win in
Georgia so that Republicans maintain control
of the Senate.
But through the end of twenty twenty, not
a dime was spent on those causes.
Maybe we don't yet have reporting for Q1 spending.
Maybe in those first five days of January,
Trump spent some of the seventy six million
on the things he promised to spend it on.
I doubt it.
He, a Republican familiar with the fundraising
fundraising operation, said, quote, He put
nothing back.
He didn't care.
He put all this money in the bank for his
own legal fights.
He never cared about Georgia's races.
But not only that, he didn't even spend the
money on vote challenges.
And if you recall, back when Trump was doing
this, we showed you the fine print, which
said, depending on which fundraising scheme
we were talking about, 50 percent or even
more of every dollar raised could go towards
the Trump campaign general fund to pay off
Trump's campaign debt.
He said it.
I mean, listen, he said it in a deceptive
way in the fine print, sort of like a software
end user agreement that's 30 pages long that
nobody reads.
Right?
I mean, but he did do it and we were reporting
it.
And it was reported so completely predictable
that this is exactly what was going to happen.
Jason Miller was asked what what happened,
Jason?
Where did the money go?
And Jason Miller so far has not responded
for comment.
Now, the truth is, Trump may well need this
money for his own legal defense.
And I think it's absolutely disgusting that
he's taking advantage of his own supporters,
who he clearly never cared about his people.
But ultimately, it's scammers and more scammers
and more scammers taking advantage of people
who are often scammers in their own ways,
people who were delighted to be bamboozled
by Trump in 2016 and wanted to continue believing
that Trump was somehow going to figure out
something even though he lost the election.
This was.
These were the perfect marks to be bamboozled
in this way, and ultimately the money is going
to the Save America Leadership Committee of
Trump.
This is nothing more than a slush fund where
the money can be used for just about anything
Trump wants.
If Trump wants to pay himself a salary out
of this money, he could do it.
And it is unbelievable that these folks fell
for it hook, line and sinker, despite the
fact that we were widely reporting that this
is exactly what was going on.
Now, when you say these people fell victims
to a scam and we should feel bad for them.
I don't know about that.
You know, it is these folks who say we don't
need a nanny state government.
We don't need the government protecting everybody
from everything all the time.
These are adults.
In the end, these are adults who presumably
voted for Trump in 2016 and or 2020.
These are adults who, despite the fact that
there was no evidence, they fell for the idea
that Trump actually won and Joe Biden didn't.
They fell for it.
I mean, look at look at everything that they
believed at some point.
Do they have any responsibility themselves
to figure out what's true?
They fell for the lie that donating to Trump
might actually change the results of an election,
even though the election everything was happening
on schedule.
There were they said, oh, December 14th is
going to be delayed and it wasn't.
And then December, what was, you know, January
six was going to be delayed.
And the riots delayed it by a couple of hours
and it wasn't.
And then the inauguration is not going and
it did.
They fell for it all.
Do they really deserve now to be bailed out
from the fact that they were scammed?
Not according to their own political philosophy,
which is no nanny state government, none of
this stuff.
So everybody but his cult knew this would
happen.
They are it's hard to even call them suckers
because they were so willing.
I don't want to call it Stockholm Syndrome.
I don't know what to call it, but they I have
a hard time now feeling as though they need
to be bailed out in some way because Trump
put it at the bottom of the emails.
It's how Trump governed.
This was the administration, the scam administration
from day one.
And these people got exactly what they voted
for, which is Trump ending up with I believe
it's the seventy six million.
I think it's 45 million in some kind of joint
fundraising account and then the other thirty
one million in that Defend America, Save America
thing that Trump himself controls.
So, you know, Trump is going to do fine financially.
Very clearly.
A lot of those folks who donated money that
they probably couldn't even really afford
to donate may now have serious financial troubles,
but they have only Trump and their own ignorance
to thank for that.
Later, by the way, we will talk about other
other scams that continue to fester related
to this administration.
But the question I have for you, I want to
hear from you on Twitter where you can find
me at Pakman.
Should we feel bad for these people who were
swindled by Trump's fundraising to the point
that somebody should bail them out?
I believe the answer is no.
I'm willing to hear other ideas.
Find me on Twitter
at David Pakman,